at the first General Affairs Council of  the year the Latvian presidency will  introduce its working program until June  the council will start with a discussion  about a revision of the multi-annual  financial framework the mff for 2014 to  2020 the aim of the revision is to allow  the EU to transfer 20 1.1 billion euros  of unused funds from 2014 for use over  the next year's the council must  unanimously adopt the revised MMF  regulation having obtained the consent  of the European Parliament following  January's events in Paris ministers will  discuss the fight against terrorism the  idea is to take stock of the actions  implemented so far and see how to move  forwards ministers will also prepare for  the Council of the EU leaders in March  the focus of the summit will be the  energy union and external relations in  particular Russia and Ukraine as well as  the Eastern Partnership summit to be  held in May